[Musik]
sorge in europa eine corona mutation in
großbritannien soll deutlich
ansteckender sein
auch deutschland stellt den flugverkehr
von dort ein weihnachten in corona
zeiten die kirchen suchen nach wegen wie
gottesdienste an den feiertagen
stattfinden können perfekter tag für
arnd peiffer der biathlet holt beim
massenstart in hochfilzen den ersten
deutschen sieg in diesem winter
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster zusammen mit norbert könig
heißen wir sie willkommen bei den
nachrichten am sonntag hallo
und die beginnen den großbritannien wo
eine neue variante des corona virus für
unruhe sorgt es verbreitet sich in
windeseile sei ausser kontrolle sagt
gesundheitsminister hancock die
bundesregierung schränkt nun den
reiseverkehr mit der insel ein denn in
deutschland ist das veränderte virus
offenbar noch nicht angekommen
aufgetreten ist die mutation vor allem
im südosten englands wo jetzt strenge
maßnahmen gelten
nach ersten erkenntnissen soll sie
deutlich ansteckender seien jedoch mit
milderen krankheitsverlauf und es gebe
keine hinweise dass die impfungen gegen
die mutation nicht wirke thomas konsum
berichtet london lichterglanz stimmung
aber fehlt das mutierte virus verdirbt
millionen menschen die festtage
rausgehen weitgehend verboten feiern nur
im eigenen haushalt weihnachten wird
einsam
die neue variante ist außer kontrolle
wir müssen sie unter kontrolle bringen
das virus soll gar nicht erst auf den
kontinent dazu kappen eu-staaten den
reiseverkehr auch deutschland flüge von
der insel eingestellt und aus südafrika
wo das virus auch mutierte wenn die
vermutung zutrifft die sich jetzt noch
weiter erweisen muss aus ersten
erkenntnissen dass dieses dieses
mutierte virus deutlich ansteckender ist
bis zu 70 prozent heißt es ja dann
verbreitet es sich natürlich auch viel
viel schneller
deswegen wollen wir den eintrag nach
deutschland noch kontinentaleuropa auch
bestmöglich und längst möglich
unterbinden zum glück ist dieses virus
in der mutierten form in deutschland von
dem was wir wissen noch nicht angekommen
wir können auch nicht wirklich sagen ob
es einstecken da ist oder nicht was man
weiß ist mutationen sind normal das
virus schleust seine erbinformation in
eine zelle ein
die kopierte info verändert sie teils
neue viren entstehen auch mutierte die
überlebensfähig sste variante setzt sich
jeweils durch sie
wie kann sich schneller verbreiten ist
aber oft ungefährlicher was bringt für
einen virus nichts wenn der wert so
schwer krank wird dass er wird das virus
nicht weiter verbreiten kann insofern
kann man davon ausgehen dass varianten
die deutlich besser sich verbreiten
auch in der regel weniger schäden
verursachen andere frage was ist mit dem
neuen impfstoff wirkt er auch gegen das
mutierte virus morgen will die eu
arzneimittelagentur das serum zu lassen
das unternehmen bei montech teilt mit
wir haben den impfstoff gegen 9.10
bekannte mutationen getestet und er hat
bei allen angeschlagen noch wenig
gewissheit beim veränderten erreger bis
auf weiteres gibt es in london und
südengland sehr stille nächte
soweit die lage in england aber theo
koll in berlin wie geht nun die
bundesregierung mit der neuen lage um
also zunächst ab mitternacht wird der
flugverkehr von und nach großbritannien
gestoppt das kann der verkehrsminister
alleine an orten und morgen wird es dann
einen kabinettsbeschluss geben der ein
weitergehendes reiseverbot umfasst auch
für die zeit nach dem 31 12
in großbritannien nicht mehr teil der eu
ist in jedem fall wird dieses veränderte
virus die pandemie bekämpfung deutlich
zurückwerfen
denn wenn die mutation wirklich 70
prozent leichter übertragbar ist dann
heißt das ein r wert von 1 läge dann
plötzlich war 1,4 und das ist eine
wirklich dramatische steigerung noch ist
die virus mutation bei uns nicht
nachgewiesen aber natürlich lässt sich
auch dieses neue virus durch keine
grenzschließung der welt aufhalten es
ist also nur eine frage der zeit bis es
hier ist die bisher gute nachricht es
gibt keine hinweise dass der impfstoff
darauf nicht anschlägt vielen dank für
den neuen informationen theo koll in
berlin
was bisher über das mutierte virus
bekannt ist haben wir für sie
aufbereitet in unserer zdf heute app und
mehr auch gleich in berlin direkt
schauen wir jetzt auf die zahlen in
deutschland die neue infektionen sind im
vergleich zur vorwoche wieder gestiegen
das robert koch institut meldet 22 1771
neue fälle innerhalb eines tages das
sind 2571 mehr als vergangenen
409 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus
seit mittwoch ist deutschland zurück im
shutdown öffentliche gottesdienste in
der weihnachtszeit aber sind erlaubt
wenn auch unter auflagen in kirchen gilt
ein mindestabstand von anderthalb metern
und auch am platz muss maske getragen
werden
gemeinsames singen ist wenn überhaupt
nur draußen erlaubt vielerorts herrscht
anmeldepflicht trotz aller regeln ein
infektionsrisiko bleibt welche
alternativen es gibt berichtet susanne
seidel singen im gottesdienst das geht
in diesen zeiten nur noch draußen wie
hier in der evangelischen schlosskirche
gemeinde in schwerin regen draußen aus
wenn ich gar nicht sehen kann
ich hoffe dass das bald besser wird mit
cola dass wir die impfung alle bekommen
und das ist wieder normal ist in der
kirche sind gottesdienste zu weihnachten
trotz steigender infektionszahlen noch
möglich die nordkirche vertraut darauf
dass jede gemeinde für sich die richtige
entscheidung trifft die illusion es
könnte so sein wie es immer war die ist
dieses jahr zerbrochen
und da gilt es einfach neue und andere
wege zu finden zum beispiel
gottesdienste zum herunterladen im netz
anbieten anleitungen für eine andacht zu
hause oder die messe per livestream zu
erste anliegen ist es leuten zu
ermöglichen ruhigen gewissens zu hause
bleiben zu können das zweite ist dass
wir trotzdem mit ihnen verbunden bleiben
wollen auf diese art und weise klaus und
maria schüler nutzen das live streaming
angebot ihrer gemeinde schon seit drei
wochen auch um mögliche ansteckungen mit
dem corona virus zu vermeiden
die kirche die gemeinschaft das gefühl
von beisammen
an heiligabend werden sie daher doch
eine messe besuchen allerdings unter
freiem himmel der shutdown in
deutschland setzt zu den läden zu der
online handel dagegen floriert aus der
unionsfraktion kommt nun die forderung
nach einer art paket steuer mit den
einnahmen solle der stationäre
einzelhandel unterstützt werden
der handelsverband sieht den vorstoß
kritisch es helfe nicht weiter die
vertriebskanäle gegeneinander
auszuspielen
im koalitionsstreit über eine bewaffnung
von bundeswehr thronen hat
cdu-generalsekretär zehn jahre
spd-kanzlerkandidat scholz scharf
angegriffen
offensichtlich sei ausgerechnet mit olaf
scholz nun außen und
sicherheitspolitische unzuverlässigkeit
neuer markenkern der spd sagte ziehm
jack scholz hatte verständnis für seine
fraktion geäußert die weiteren
diskussionsbedarf angemeldet hatte
außenminister maas sprach sich heute für
eine drohnen bewaffnung aus zum schutz
der soldaten
trotz polizeigewalt gibt es in belarus
weiter proteste gegen machthaber
lukaschenko jeden sonntag seit 19 wochen
so auch heute
die demonstranten versammelten sich in
ihren wohnvierteln mit der taktik wollen
sie der polizei den zugriff erschweren
ihre förderung der rücktritt von
lukaschenko und neuwahlen
rund 100 menschen sollen festgenommen
worden sein
und jetzt zum sonntag sport und norbert
könig ja zunächst mit einem
erfolgreichen 30 biathleten am kiefer 33
jahre alt sieg beim massenstart in
hochfilzen erster saisonsieg für die
deutschen männer und eine besondere
freude für ihn als jubel ist auch
deshalb so groß weil es an aller erster
triumph in einem massenstartrennen ist
über die 15 kilometer mit insgesamt vier
schießeinlagen blieb der 33-jährige als
einzige aus der spitzengruppe fehlerfrei
traf alle 20 scheiben auch benedikt doll
erzielte mit nur einer strafrunde als
vierter ein hervorragendes ergebnis das
entscheidende überholmanöver gelang
tiefer im zweikampf mit dem schweden
konzil oma kurz vor der zielgeraden
astrium versorgt vier tage vor
heiligabend für einen versöhnlichen
jahresabschluss platz drei belegt der
norweger tarjei bö weltmeister markus
eisenbichler muss sich beim skispringen
in engelberg nur weltcup-spitzenreiter
halveraner reid geschlagen geben
stark gesprungen und gelaufen ist
vincent geiger rechts er gewinnt genau
wie gestern im sprint gegen den norweger
rieber die nordische kombination in
ramsau das erste bundesliga
sonntagsspiel hat freiburg gegen hat der
bsc 4 zu 1 gewonnen und ist jetzt
zehnter und am sonntag vor weihnachten
ist es guter brauch im zdf die
sportlerin den sportler und die
mannschaft des jahres zu ehren rudi
cerne und katrin müller-hohenstein
werden trotz corona nicht allein auf der
bühne stehen januar das ein bisschen
einsam als sonst aber der glamour faktor
bleibt denn wir haben sie natürlich
trotzdem alle die sportlerin den
sportler und die mannschaft des jahres
darstellen wird diese auszeichnung ist
außerordentlich hoch
es ist der oscar des deutschen sports
und wir haben eine neuheit eine
zusätzliche auszeichnung wir zeichnen
nämlich die sport legenden des
vergangenen jahrzehnts aus und die
beiden spielen dabei eine hauptrolle
magdalena neuner und dirk nowitzki
bis nachher 18 vielen dank nachbarn
waren wir sind dabei natürlich zum
schluss noch ein blick auf das feuchte
winter wetter morgen teils aufgelockert
teils stark bewölkt im westen kommt
wieder regen auf bei südwind vier bis
elf grad
das war es von uns danke dass sie dabei
waren
marietta slomka und das heute journal um
drei viertel 10
und an dieser stelle erwartet sie morgen
christian sievers